you don't announce that you're running
for president of the United States
in some kind of little Twitter world
it's not a real world Twitter is not
real so I can't comprehend why that
would be the place to do the
announcement it makes no sense it's not
serious okay so Marjorie Taylor green
says DeSantis isn't serious remember
that there are there is the belief that
Trump will pick a woman to be his
running mate this time around the four
women whose names are being floated are
Marjorie Taylor green Carrie Lake Nikki
Haley who's running against Trump and
Christy gnome from South Dakota who it's
not even clear if she's interested and
it's not even really clear if she's the
top Contender so arguably Marjorie
Taylor green participating in this in
service to supporting her own potential
candidacy to be Donald Trump's vice
president